i was thinking um
how
oh this thought is a bit escape me i was
thinking firstly odd that the british
empire is not pushing back against this
stuff uh i would like to see them no
it's their policy it isn't what their
policy why is it their policy but like
uh that what's happening maybe a lot of
these activists of the people that are
pushing these things are childless
people trying to parent other humans
because like when you're an adult you're
like your kid starts crying i know
you're sad i know you're upset but i'm
doing this for your own good and they
may actually be doing that because
you're taming a wild one you're
basically you can't eat all the sugar i
know it's sad i know it sucks but trust
me so these people are doing it for
other people i know it's not the
language you're used to but trust me
it's for your own good like have some
kids gain some humility stop trying to
control people i was thinking about this
like why don't you just let the kid eat
the tuba cookie dough no no because it's
addictive no no because a kid would barf
all over himself and be like i never
wanted to go but then they keep eating
it they go back to it like a dog pukes
eating it
i learned my lesson when i i remember i
moved to la and i was hungry and i ate a
whole pizza to myself and i was like
that was so good and then i got sick and
i was like i'm never doing this again oh
i made a mistake and i was an adult when
that happened oh i was i made that
mistake as a kid over and over and over
again but but i think there is there's a
point there it's uh because it's it's
what we've said before uh the the
socialists don't have kids they have
yours correct like uh if you think about
it like from that analogy like you
treat your family as like a commune
right you treat your friend group as a
socialist circle
the wider you go the more right-wing
think you go like you treat the country
as like you want to get the best out of
people so you want
there's there needs to be like a
capitalist structure but for someone who
doesn't have a kid or family or friends
for that matter they want to enforce
their control over the next immediate
group of people that they see and in
this case that's
the rest of the citizen of the country
yeah it's probably naturally um
satisfying to have a little bit of
communism a little bit of socialism
correct yeah like because you have a
right side of your brain on the left
side of your brain you need that balance
just to be a functioning human being and
you use the
left way of thinking for the people who
you actually care about or you have
something to share with like the people
from your same religious circle
or your family or your friends or your
family but the people who you do not
know like strangers you just want the
best out of each other so you think of
them like hey let's be symbolic and you
get the best out of me and i get the
best out of you and there's money
involved
so there comes like a capitalist way of
thinking
but if you don't have any kids family or
like a religious circle you don't have
anyone to use that left way of thinking
on so you subject that on the rest of
the people have you guys uh seen those
groomer bills they haven't i think it's
florida banned them yeah it was like you
know that the schools wanted to like you
know groom children into
various
ideas or whatever i'm saying that very
specifically i'm i'm i'm using the
phrase groomer on purpose because what
the left is really effective at is
propaganda and what they're saying is
they're calling it don't say gay oh you
i heard it right you've heard of that
wait was i i don't know that what's that
so it's just they're bill saying that
schools shouldn't be having uh
like sex ed for kids as part of the
curriculum it should be something
special or not in schools at all should
be something that parents decide and
that's you know my attitude on it is
like yeah i don't know the parents
should figure out they want to talk to
their kids about this stuff so the left
has very um
they're good they're good at the stuff
they call it the don't say gay
so that's clearly not what the bill is
but now all of a sudden that's what the
left is is putting out there and
when i say groomer bill you guys are
like huh what's that it's because the
right is ineffective right yeah they
don't they don't have any of that stuff
but you know in these schools
indoctrination is is the key to what
what the left is doing they don't have
kids they have yours which means if they
can get your kids to believe whatever
they believe in 20 years this country
will be
whatever their ideology is it's starting
with millennials no all the stuff rising
up and you're right on point and we
actually did uh me signing we produced
our second doc uh documentary was called
indoctrination nation where we looked at
critical race theory in the state of
virginia pacific aladdin county
one thing that i was shocked about was
that these kids would be like 12 years
old and listen you know they'll go to
like to the library and their librarian
would tell them hey you should read this
book it's called rick
and rick is you know will be a story
about a girl who then transitioned into
a boy and all this is happening without
the parents knowledge yeah it wasn't
until those to those kids come actually
home and say hey mom this is what i
learned and then you know the parents
look at it like wait wait what um so
it's a little bit of actually actually
that that you know indoctrination at a
very young age and it's doing behind the
parents back also in in my home state of
california we had a state assembly
member by the name of scott weiner who
actually is introducing a bill which
actually might pass which is scary a
bill that's going to lower the age of
vaccination consent down from the age of
18 down to 12 years old so could you
imagine that if you're a 12 year old or
13 year old if your mom says you can't
get vaccinated or you know because
obviously she's your parent but now you
could finally go behind your parents
back and still still do this and you
know give more power to this you know
look i i gotta say i blame a lot of the
parents 100
uh i can't tell you how many stories
i've heard where it's like i sent my
daughter to college and now she hates me
and it's like why would you do that why
would you not pay attention to what you
were doing to your children look i get
it man these these cult weirdos are the
problem
but who are i got to say to parents out
there you didn't look into the school
where you didn't go and visit you didn't
ask about the curriculum you didn't
check in on what other people go to the
school are doing and what they what
they're planning with what's happened to
their lives you're not doing any
research it's crazy to me how many
parents are like i just put my kid in
school and forget about it and then when
their kid comes back and like i can't
believe you're learning this did you not
take any active role in what's happening
to your kids that that version of for
lack of a better word helicopter
parenting is
kind of a privilege if you think about
it right so if there's
helicopter parenting
like for lack of a better what i said
like well i'm not talking about parents
like micromanaging their kids lives i'm
talking about their parents knowing
about the college they're sending their
kids to instead of being like i signed
the paper by it's like shouldn't you be
like i looked into these schools here's
what i think is best good luck to you
that's fair but what i'm trying to say
is like
that's not possible for you know
a family who's just trying to get by or
like a single like a single mom who's
working a job already and who's just
sending their kid
to public school expecting that
everything's going to be on autopilot
like that's not possible for her and
what what where did this idea come from
because it's a new idea that you could
use schools as a daycare center and you
weren't responsible for what you know oh
i i thought the schools the government
indoctrinated institution i thought the
government's institutionalized learning
facilities was going to teach my kid to
be responsible adults who got good jobs
did it ever occur to anybody that when
the government is subsidizing an
institutionalized learning facility the
number one uh function of any entity is
to preserve itself so they're going to
indoctrinate your kids to want to
preserve their machine
if you want your kids to to retain your
values
you are responsible and no one else and
if you send your kids to these colleges
you are responsible for them coming back
with shaved heads and like pierced eyes
or something
but like
what would you say to
a mom like that who doesn't have any
other option than to send her kid to a
public school um i think that uh the
challenge today
is how luxurious we all live
excuse me
you go back 100 years this wasn't an
issue you know uh well maybe a little
bit more than a hundred years i would
say even when i was in high school
wasn't an issue i mean i wasn't get
getting taught the stuff that these kids
i mean i was like basic stuff you were
still in an institutionalized learning
facility yeah absolutely your teachers
had liberal left left lefty values even
going back 20 or 30 years conservative
parents put their kids in schools and
their kids came out liberal it's just
that liberal has gone further and
further left as a recent history so and
the internet has really accelerated this
but there was a period where parents
didn't have refrigerators didn't have
cell phones didn't have the internet
didn't have cars and life sucked
but
as much as it did relative to today
they would take responsibility for their
kids their kids would work with them the
problem now is
when someone says i have to have a job
well it's because you want to maintain
modern living standards which i totally
get and respect who wouldn't why why
would who wants to go live in a cave and
try and forage for berries not to
mention it's really hard because
property is basically owned by everybody
but there is the big challenge the
system is ossifying around you to such a
degree you will have no choice but to
send your kids to institutionalized
learning facilities where they will be
taught to hate you hate everything about
you and your family and your history
your country and your culture and if you
don't like it too bad because your job
is more important living in a house with
air conditioning and a refrigerator
absolutely is more important and i mean
that you're going to starve to death
you're going to have no food you're
going to have dirty drinking water and
live on the streets no you're going to
have to live in this system as
prescribed and that means the state will
own your kids unless you can figure
something out unless you stand up and
you vote and like we saw in virginia
young can you know comes in or whatever
so may i'm not saying it's the end it's
not i'm just saying this is the system
that has been built all around us and it
is a terrifying one because how do you
escape it when you are trapped in it you
can't just go uh uh you know to the
woods as much as i might jokingly say
like get out there and go to the forest
i mean like you literally can't just
live off the land anymore it's owned by
everybody there's rules there's laws and
regulations if you are if you are well
off enough and you save save up enough
money you can buy land in the middle of
nowhere it's not impossible you can buy
a house out in west virginia for 100k
you get a loan you put down a thousand
bucks if you get a good loan there you
go move out there you'll work a lot more
life won't be as easy but at least
you'll know your kids will retain your
values and won't come back with their
heads shaved believing in saying things
i was looking at the history of public
education modern education in the
american system uh comes from a guy
named john dewey he was one of the
founders of what's called the
progressive education movement and he
believed that schools this is from
wikipedia uh that we're not only a place
for students to gain content knowledge
but also a place for them to learn how
to live
so to this day the schools are still
teaching people kids how to think and i
agree teaching kids how to learn is
important but when you're teaching them
how to think as in like how how to be
racist
i think the the aberration has grown
bigger than the product at this point
you know i mean i think you know maybe
i'm wrong but at the end of the day
all this still goes down to the parents
so you know even if you know at the end
of the day with the world that we're
living in here in america you're going
to send out your kids as you know
whether it's woke is left to stuff at
school work it's it's going to be all
around them so it's up to the family to
kind of build those structure and values
before you kind of head out to the real
world that's just my opinion i think you
know what my parents did with me i think
helped me out so when i went to the real
world saw some of this stuff i'm like oh
no f that's like when i went out to the
real world one thing that was getting
taught a lot when i was in community
college was the white privilege thing so
you know i would have white professors
or white um other students tell me how
i'm oppressed and i'm like no i'm not
like my dad's an immigrant who escaped
the civil war you know he just taught me
that i have to work hard and that's how
i get ahead i'm not you know we're not
we're not not ahead because we're not
white or anything so i think it's at the
end of the day no matter with all the
propaganda around us and everything it
still just comes down to mom and dad and
the values that you're getting taught in
your health yeah i can't imagine that
the school's job is to teach people how
to how to learn how to live
come on john dewey says the school is
the place for them to learn how to live
that's the parent's job is to teach i
mean to be honest i never heard the word
white privilege so like i was like 19
years old 20 years old um just because
like it's just my house i was never
taught that you know my mom and dad were
like hey you have to grind you have to
work my dad the mindset he taught me was
first one in the office last one out so
when i was raised like that i just never
heard the word right white people i
didn't even know it was a thing until i
was like 19 years old in community
college and kids were like hey hori
you're you're in community college
because of white privilege i was like no
i'm not i just you know i just messed
around in high school and that's why
that's what i'm here and i deserve it i
see value to organized education because
i imagine before john dewey was around
that it was just madness like one
schoolhouse would be teaching this the
other one would be teaching this they'd
say the word means this thing they say
the word means that so they developed a
centralized authority that basically
tells us like this is the official
information but now you see how horrible
that can become when they feed you crap
another thing which like the
conservatives
left the ball was
this whole concept of they will get
reality checked once they graduate and
face the real world oh yeah because that
never happened for most of these kids i
was wrong about that for sure
i was saying that and what happens is
they get out and they all stand around
looking at each other going the world
isn't the way it's supposed to be so
we're going to force it and the way
we're going to do it is by taking over
the hr departments of corporate america
and that's what gets overlooked so much
like people try to find cause and effect
that's the cause right there
well uh the laws look um
you've got
the civil rights law which we like but
they take it to the extreme they say uh
you know one of the arguments put
forward by the left is about
separate but equal when it comes to race
and then they say all of those arguments
pertain to gender as well
why why have so if the argument was that
you know different races were different
therefore they get equal access to a
bathroom but there's different bathrooms
based on race why the same for gender if
the genders are legal are equal under
the law how can you say separate but
equal it's an argument actually being
made by the left over the gender issue
and based on
the the interpretation of the law
there's that they have a legal argument
so there has to be a reinterpretation or
it has to be a judicial review or
something
but so long as these laws exist they
will exploit them in ways they were
never intended they will change language
to
retroactively change the laws without
any real democratic process
they they're look
these these cult members are good at
what they do in terms of
they're really good like if you think
about it right now it is almost
synonymous
to a layman like there is no difference
between equity and equality right people
just throw thro throw around the world
diversity and equity
like it means nothing like it used to be
when i was in school it was diversity
and equality and we were like i knew
what those words meant and i know what
equality and equity is and what the
difference is yeah equity is communism
yeah equity is the quality of outcome
and
equality is equal of opportunities as
simple as that but right now to a layman
there is no difference right because the
the
the left has been so so so
good at
messaging thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast if
you want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at 8
00 pm and don't forget to smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
and if you want more unfiltered and
uncensored content with all of these
guests go to timcast.com and become a
member all of these guests you know and
love in exclusive segments on our
website where we are unrestricted in
what we talk about so you'll definitely
not want to miss it thanks for hanging
out we'll see you all next time